13h devant l'une des deux usines mbf de
saint claude
c'est l'heure de la relève pour les 260
salariés de l'entreprise et les 40
intérimaires
le moral n'est pas au beau fixe bien sûr
qu'on a peur pour notre emploi d'autant
plus que ça fait d'ailleurs on a déjà eu
le même cas en 2008 2012
lassé on veut dire c'est encore la même
situation
bien sûr qu'on a peur pour notre sport
non sans colère quoi ce qu'on nous a
menti cacher des choses quoi on a tout
donné ce qu'on avait à donner et puis
voilà où on en est maintenant quand on
est un peu dépité mais le boulot
continue et a du boulot c'est ça que je
comprends il ya du boulot
et puis là la boîte elle est en train de
finir de mettre en péril sa je comprends
pas en redressement judiciaire depuis le
4 novembre dernier c'est ce matin lors
d'un comité central d'entreprise que mbf
devait connaître son éventuel repreneur
autour de la table les partenaires
sociaux l'administrateur judiciaire est
l'actionnaire principal jean-pierre au
cola si depuis fin janvier le groupe
américain sait qu est le concurrent
français gmd avaient déposé des lettres
d'intention de reprise
ils ont tous les deux jeter l'épongé
faute de garanties de la part des
constructeurs
on a eu notre actionnaire qui étaient là
donc qui lui est prêt apparemment à
faire un plan de continuation
il nous a parlé nous a dit qu'il était
en contact avec certaines personnes et
que donc il va préparer un dossier
par contre on ne sait pas quand il va le
présenter
contactée la direction n'a pas souhaité
s'exprimer l'administrateur judiciaire
lui laisse désormais jusqu'au 1er mars
minuit pour d'autres projets de reprise
un nouveau comité central d'entreprise
aura lieu le 2 mars avant de passer
devant le tribunal de commerce le
lendemain